il n'est pas encore élu mais pour ces
soutiens le doute n'est plus permis à
lire ab arrive en tête du premier tour
pour les élections municipales à trappes
avec près de 37% des voix il devance de
10 points ses principaux concurrents
je salue aussi mes concurrents qui sont
arrivés deuxièmes et troisièmes othman
nastro qui incarne la droite trappistes
qui rassemblait les suffrages de la
famille politique qui est la sienne à
27% et guy malandain maire sortant qui
arrivait en troisième position que je
salue pour le travail qu'il a pu
réaliser pendant maintenant plus de 20
ans mais que j'invite à prendre ses
responsabilités dans un cadre classique
et celui de du rassemblement deuxième
tour de la gauche républicaine est
distancé après 20 ans de mandat le maire
sortant guy malandain ne semble pas
disposer pour l'instant à soutenir son
ancien adjoint à la jeunesse et aux
sports
si vraiment un deuxième tour confirmait
le premier tour j'ai beaucoup
d'inquiétude pour l'avenir de la ville
il y a des gens de droite des maires de
droite que je connais qui gèrent bien
leur vie des mères de l'ouche si j en
crois bien en ville et vice versa trois
situations compliquées aussi à
villepreux pour le maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau n'est que troisième
du premier tour avec un peu moins de 19%
des suffrages exprimés il est largement
devancé par son ancien adjoint jean
baptiste à monique premier en récoltant
39% des voix des villes prose hier
depuis les dernières semaines de
campagne on sentait une vraie dynamique
sur le terrain une dynamique qui
s'amplifiait de jour en jour nous on va
continuer droits dans nos bottes en tout
cas on va continuer à dérouler le projet
qu'on a présenté au premier tour
maintient le cap on maintient la ligne
et puis on sera dans une logique
évidemment de rassemblement quand on met
un numéro 3 alors qu'on est le maire
depuis du coup depuis douze ans qu'on a
un bilan qui est quand même plutôt pas
mal
on est quand même extrêmement déçu de
terminer 3 à ce stade je peux vous
assurer que je serai encore présents
avec les membres de ma liste est gérée
elle déposé tout cela à la préfecture
demain je ne baisse pas les bras et en
tout cas je ne me battrai jusqu'au bout
bien évidemment pas de maire sortant aux
clayes-sous-bois mais plusieurs anciens
élus de la majorité en ballottage pour
le second tour anne claire frémont se
place troisième avec 24% des voix
nicolas hulot candidat de la gauche et
membre de l'opposition municipale
récolte lui 26% c'est philippe guiguen
l'actuel adjoint aux finances qui se
place en tête avec 31,7 % de votants
pour sa liste enfin eux aussi font la
course en tête après ce premier tour les
maires des villes de plaisir guyancourt
voisins le bretonneux et la verrière
peuvent aborder le second tour plus ou
moins sereinement si second tour il y a